Donald Trump lo tiene claro, claro meridiano:
no va a desistir. Continúa adelante con su
empeño de desatar su particular guerra mundial…
en este caso toda una guerra comercial contra
el resto del mundo.
(Somos el banco del que todo el mundo roba.
Respeto a China y al presidente Xi, ¡pero
nos han estado matando!)
Convencido de que los Estados Unidos están
siendo perjudicados e incluso “robados”
en sus relaciones comerciales, en los últimos
meses Donald Trump ha puesto en marcha una
dura política proteccionista y ha multiplicado
los aranceles.
Desde ahora, miles y miles de millones de
dólares en productos importados por Estados
Unidos tendrán que hacer frente a los fuertes
aranceles aprobados por esta administración.
[Ya sabes: compra productos estadounidenses…
Si no, es que no eres un auténtico patriota.
Bienvenidos a 1930]
(Pues bien, el caso es que durante este mes
de Julio de 2018 comenzarán a aplicarse aranceles
- ni más ni menos que del 25% - sobre productos
que Estados Unidos importa cada año de China
por valor de 50.000 millones de dólares.
Además, apenas unos meses antes, la Casa
Blanca puso en marcha aranceles contra las
importaciones de acero, aluminio, placas solares
e incluso lavadoras.)
Pero, por supuesto, no penséis que aquí termina
todo… para nada. Trump ya tiene sobre la
mesa planes para poner en marcha próximamente
muchos más aranceles.
[¿Has jugado alguna vez al Monopoly o al
Risk? Pues...Digamos que a ojos del presidente
norteamericano todo este asunto es algo así
como un juego de mesa,… y, amigos... no
está dispuesto a perder]
(Mi nuevo juego es “Trump: el juego”.
Trump, el juego, donde negocias por todo lo
que siempre has querido poseer. Porque no
se trata de lo que ganes o pierdas, sino de
si ganas o no. Creo que te gustará)
Ahora bien… ¿va a resultar realmente tan
sencillo?… ¿Se cumplirá el plan del presidente
norteamericano y la economía se fortalecerá
con este tipo de políticas? Estas son las
preguntas clave.
De momento, lo que ya sabemos es que el discurso
de Donald Trump está empezando a crear muchos,
pero que muchos nervios en las multinacionales
norteamericanas.
(“No creo que esto vaya a resolverse fácilmente
y creo que estas tarifas van a perjudicar
a la economía norteamericana", Rufus Yerxa,
Presidente del Consejo Nacional de comercio
exterior, que representa a multinacionales
como Coca-Cola, Ford y Microsoft.
Y es que… lejos de lo prometido, las primeras
víctimas están siendo norteamericanas. Atentos.
(¿EL SUEÑO ROTO?)
En la Casa Blanca lo repiten una y otra vez,
esta nueva política tiene como objetivo impulsar
a las empresas estadounidenses…
Sin embargo, antes de que los partidarios
de Trump lancen las campanas al vuelo, esperad
un momento porque hay algunas cosas que el
presidente no cuenta.
La primera es que la inmensa mayor parte de
los aranceles se están aplicando sobre bienes
intermedios y de capital, esto es, los bienes
que las empresas importan para fabricar sus
productos en los Estados Unidos…. De tal
forma que una de dos:
o pagan el arancel o empiezan a empiezan comprar
en otros mercados o suponiendo que sea posible
en los propios Estados Unidos…. En cualquier
caso eso supone un mayor coste de producción…
lo que, evidentemente, reduce la competitividad
de las empresas del país.
(Este es por ejemplo, el caso de Mid-Continent
Nail, una empresa de Missouri que es la mayor
productora de clavos de Estados Unidos y que
tras los aranceles aprobados por Trump al
acero extranjero ha tenido que despedir ya
a 60 de sus 500 empleados y todo apunta a
que podría verse obligada a cerrar o trasladar
toda su producción a México.)
Una empresa que funcionaba, que creaba empleo,
que era competitiva en un mercado libre y
que ahora por la intromisión de Washington
se está viniendo abajo.
Luego, la segunda cuestión, seguro que no
os sorprendo, es que el resto de países no
se están quedando quietos.
("Para defender los intereses centrales del
país y los intereses del pueblo, nos vemos
obligados a tomar represalias", Declaración
del Ministerio de Comercio de China.)
(“Ojo por ojo: Europa responde con más
aranceles a la guerra comercial de Donald
Trump. El Mundo)
[¿Qué tu me pones un arancel… pues yo
te pongo otro. Y así, suma y sigue. No tendría
porqué ser así, pero... lo es.]
El caso es que las consecuencias no se han
hecho esperar.
Harley Davidson, el popular fabricante de
motos, uno de los grandes íconos de los Estados
Unidos y un orgullo nacional en palabras,
ojo, del propio Trump… ha anunciado ahora
que trasladará parte de su producción desde
sus fábricas en Estados Unidos hacia nuevas
fábricas en Europa.
Veréis… cuando Trump castigó a la Unión
Europea con aranceles sobre el acero y el
aluminio, esta respondió con más aranceles…
por ejemplo incrementó del 6 al 31% el arancel
sobre las importaciones de motos fabricadas
en Estados Unidos.
(Algunos están sugiriendo que deberíamos
proteger a las empresas de EE.UU. de competidores
extranjeros. No creo que el pueblo americano
tenga miedo de competir. Eso me quedó claro
cuando visité una fábrica de Harley-Davidson
hace poco. Cuando escuchas hablar de leyes
de comercio duras recuerda que ser duro contra
el comercio, la savia de la economía, podría
tener las peores consecuencias posibles para
el consumidor y el trabajador americano. Como
les dije en la fábrica de Harley-Davidson,
es hora de pisar el acelerador no de frenar.)
¿Cuanto supone esto? Pues… aproximadamente,
de media, unos 2.200$ por cada moto.
Un coste, al que evidentemente, no tendrán
que hacer frente las motos de los fabricantes
europeos como BMW… y, gracias a un acuerdo
comercial entre la Unión Europea y Japón,
tampoco las de Yamaha, Kawasaki, Honda…
Es decir, los principales competidores de
Harley Davidson.
(“Esta es una prueba más del daño de los
aranceles unilaterales [...] La mejor manera
de ayudar a los trabajadores estadounidenses,
consumidores y fabricantes es abrir nuevos
mercados para ellos, no elevar las barreras
a nuestro propio mercado” , Paul Ryan, congresista
republicano por Wisconsin y presidente de
la cámara de representantes.)
Y tal y como os podéis imaginar teniendo
en cuenta el carácter de Donald Trump, esta
noticia le hizo ponerse furioso… e incluso
llegó a amenazar por Twitter, claro, a la
propia compañía.
¡Una Harley-Davidson nunca deberia ser construida
en ningún otro país! Sus empleados y clientes
ya están muy enfadados con ellos. Si se trasladan,
atentos, será el principio del fin - se rindieron,
renunciaron. ¡El Aura se esfumará y se les
pondrán impuestos como nunca antes!
[¿Un presidente amenazando y dañando la
imagen de una gran empresa estadounidense
por el simple hecho de tomar sus decisiones.
Bienvenidos a la Norteamérica de Trump]
Ahora bien, una pregunta que nos podemos hacer,
es ¿Necesita realmente la mítica compañía
de motos trasladar parte de su producción
a Europa? Atentos.
(¿NECESITA HARLEY DAVIDSON MIRAR AL MUNDO?)
Amigos, las norteamericanas tienen suficientes
retos y problemas como para encima tener que
soportar las grandes ideas [o disparates que
nacen en la Casa Blanca.
Veréis la guerra comercial de Trump ha tenido
un impacto fuerte en empresas como Harley-Davidson:
por un lado sus costes se han incrementado
por los aranceles al acero y al aluminio [Sólo
en el caso de la empresa de motos eso ha supuesto
20 millones de dólares cada año]; por otro…
las multinacionales norteamericanas ahora
se enfrentan al riesgo de ver como sus mercados
se cierran.
(“El aumento de la producción internacional
para aliviar la carga arancelaria de la UE
no es la preferencia de la empresa, sino que
representa la única opción sostenible para
hacer que sus motocicletas sean accesibles
a los clientes de la UE y mantener un negocio
viable en Europa. Europa es un mercado crítico
para Harley-Davidson.” Declaración corporativa
de Harley Davidson.)
Y es que esta crisis ha azotado a la mítica
de empresa de motos en un momento ya de por
sí delicado.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en cómo ha evolucionado
su cotización en bolsa en los últimos 4
años.
Pero…¿ a qué se debe esta enorme caída
de más del 40% en unos años en que la bolsa
norteamericana, además, ha subido como un
cohete?
Pues.. básicamente la explicación, amigos,
está en el cambio de época...hubo un día
que este tipo de motos, enormes, potentes,
ruidosas y fabricadas en casa eran el sueño
de muchos, casi de una mayoría de los norteamericanos...
Sin embargo, tanto por precio [son carísimas]
como por cambio de gustos, a las generaciones
de hoy este tipo de motos ya no les llama
tanto… De hecho, la edad media de los propietarios
de una Harley en Estados Unidos supera los
50 años.
(Y eso, como os podéis imaginar, se traduce,
perfectamente en la cifra de ventas y beneficios:
tan solo en los últimos 3 años las ventas
de la compañía se han reducido un 10% y
los beneficios en casi un 40%.
Y en 2018 las cosas van aún peor…)
Así que amigos, esta es la razón por la
que esta empresa necesita si o si mirar al
exterior… tanto a Europa como a Asia…
y si no hay libertad comercial y hay aranceles…
la producción tendrá que marcharse a otros
lugares.
Y es que NO, la decisión de Harley-Davidson
no tiene nada que ver con política y desde
luego no es ninguna “traición”.
Se trata simple y llanamente la decisión
económica, comprensible y lógica de una
empresa que tiene que competir…. algo que
por cierto no le está siendo fácil y que
ahora además tiene que hacer frente a las
consecuencias de la guerra comercial desatada
por Washington.
Pero… ¿Sabéis qué? No es un caso aislado.
(LAS MULTINACIONALES)
Las políticas de Trump dañan a las empresas
norteamericanas y por extensión a la economía
estadounidense. Y cuanto más allá lleve
la guerra mayores serán las consecuencias.
De momento las multinacionales norteamericanas
- algunas de las cuales habían apoyado a
Trump o se habían puesto de perfil - se están
poniendo muy pero que muy nerviosas con todo
este asunto.
La mismísima General Motors ha dicho que
si el presidente finalmente aprueba aranceles
a la importación de vehículos, algo que
se están planteando en la Casa Blanca, las
consecuencias serían menos inversión, menos
empleos y menos salarios para los trabajadores
de General Motors en Estados Unidos.
Pongamos como ejemplo, el caso de otro ícono
de los Estados Unidos… el Ford Mustang…
que, por supuesto, es ensamblado en Estados
Unidos y exportado desde aquí al resto del
mundo. Atentos.
(Algo más del 48% de las piezas, de los componentes
del Mustang proceden de fuera de los Estados
Unidos… así que si a todas esas importaciones
las castigas con aranceles… el resultado
es el de un coche más caro tanto para los
consumidores estadounidenses como para la
exportación… )
[Un momento, ¿Las Harley-Davidson y el Ford
Mustang, dos de los grandes iconos de Estados
Unidos afectados por las políticas de Trump?
Menudo éxito]
Y luego también empresas de otros países
que tienen fábricas en Estados Unidos como
Toyota, Fiar-Chrysler, Daimler o BMW están
alertando de los peligros de esta guerra.
La matriz de Mercedes Benz, Daimler, advierte
que la batalla de aranceles entre EEUU y China
impactará en sus ganancias, específicamente
de sus SUVs hechos en Alabama.
Pero, ojo… no se trata ni mucho menos de
algo que afecta solo a la industria automovilística,
es algo que afecta a prácticamente todos
los sectores.
Por que si, es verdad, Estados Unidos es la
mayor economía del planeta, pero, ojo, no
lo olvidéis, el 85% del PIB y la inmensa
mayor parte del crecimiento está fuera de
sus fronteras. Encerrarse es un mal negocio.
Levantar barreras va, precisamente, contra
los intereses de una país que actualmente
está en pleno empleo, con un número récord
de trabajadores y con la mayor producción
industrial de su historia.
Sí lo sé, Donald Trump habla mucho del déficit
comercial… y es verdad que existe… pero
no por los motivó que el plantea. Estados
Unidos no tiene un déficit comercial porque
siendo robado, ni mucho menos, sino porque
básicamente el país tiene una economía
que consume más de lo que produce.
Si Donald Trump quiere reducir el déficit
puede por ejemplo, frenar el inmenso gasto
público que tantos peligros está causando,
como ya vimos en este vídeo; puede promover
el ahorro, la inversión para que sus empresas
sean más productivas, entre otras muchas
cosas.
Pero desde luego… la guerra comercial es
un mal negocio para todos.
Pero ahora turno para ti: ¿Apoyas esta guerra
comercial?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta. Si te ha resultado
interesante el vídeo, echanos una mano dando
a like y compartiendolo.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.